ten nine eight seven six five four three
two one zero the kitchen
vehicles pitches downrange
hey you got a car right now
vehicles supersonic coming up on one
minute in the flight we're getting ready
for maximum dynamic pressure
vehicle has reached maximum aerodynamic
pressure
you've heard the call-out we're through
the region of maximum aerodynamic
pressure vehicle going supersonic as we
leave the denser parts of the lower
Earth's atmosphere Falcon 9 trajectory
looks good all 9 Merlin engines are at
power everything looking good for Falcon
9 we're heading due east from Cape
Canaveral headed to the first of two
orbits planned for today nice view from
the onboard camera looking back at the
plume slowly expanding as we leave the
atmosphere the plume will get larger as
we get up to the vacuum of space
now today first stage shutdown is
planned for about t plus two minutes 45
seconds we won't be recovering the first
stage today so that leaves more
propellant to burn to achieve the
required orbit for the satellite if you
compare that to last week's CRS 18
resupply flight to the space station on
that mission the first stage shut down
almost half a minute sooner than today
we needed to reserve enough propellant
to be able to turn the first stage and
return it all the way back to the launch
site now coming up quickly in 20 seconds
a sequence of events main engine cutoff
the nine main engine shutdown stage
separation and end ignition of the
second stage engine coming up in just
under 15 seconds
we go
a BIST separation confirmed
[Applause]